meanwhile we are also working to
send
material to Turkey to Syria
So our Civil Defense is a
perfect collaboration with the Ministry
of Defense
defense and that material are offered
private individuals through the mediation of the
Red Crescent also to Syria we will send
the material to Beirut and then  it will arrive in
Syria we had tried to deliver it
directly to Apple but then we
were advised against due to the
security conditions So we should pass
the two ministries are working 24 hours a day
To do everything possible
together with the civil protection to
bring help to these populations I tell
the  Italian journalists Unfortunately,
compatriots are missing, they
are Mr. Angelo Zen
who was the first one
we tracked down but who didn't
answer our calls, plus there is
a family
of Syrian origin But
three
adults and three who have Italian citizenship  minors
who are no longer heard from we
are in contact with their
families and our firefighters who
are present
in Turkey are doing everything in fact I
want to thank you on behalf of the government
for all the extraordinary work
they are doing they have already saved more than
a person thanks to their ability
thanks to their
experience
after this huge tragedy does
not
force
the rescuers to face enormous
difficulties there are areas that
cannot be reached even in cities
where there is the presence of the emergency services it is
difficult to reach areas where they have
been destroyed  that
many buildings have collapsed, many
buildings have collapsed, therefore it is really complicated to
bring help, therefore we
will continue to update all of
you on the situation, however, compared to
last night, there have been no
changes except those related to
the sending of material. A ship has left
to send military to send
relief supplies to Turkey And thank you always
to the armed forces who are doing
exceptional work to
bring relief Here I believe that
in the next few days within the week
the vehicles will leave which will bring
material that even private individuals have
donated
for the populations of Syria I repeat
through the Red Crescent we know
because of the sanctions we do not have
an ambassador in Damascus
there is a charge d'affaires in Beirut
who has now gone to
Syria and is in contact with the
Red Crescent who will mediate As
the  Minister Crosetto we cannot
bring the relief material
directly to Syria So it will be a
red crescent through the
mediation of the Ministry of Foreign Affairs to
deliver the material to the populations
who are victims of the earthquake We are
doing everything the President of the
Republic the Prime Minister
are  constantly updated on what
our administrations are doing
to try to help populations that
have suffered enormous devastation A
talking in Northern Italy Action in favor
Turkey and Syria
Thank you good afternoon everyone I am
very pleased to once again
welcome two friends  the secretary of
state responsible for foreign affairs
Cleverley and the secretary of state
responsible for defense Wallace
together with Guido Crosetto we
strongly supported these
foreign defense consultations between Italy and the United Kingdom
because we are convinced that
cooperation between these sectors is
fundamental and must be conducted
simultaneously  the relations between our
countries are relations that have
ancient roots we are part of NATO we are
both committed to the defense of the
independence of Ukraine we are
both part of the G7 of the G20 of course
we work hand in hand in the fight
against
terrorism there is a  excellent climate
of collaboration We are strongly
committed together in the quintet that
works for the stabilization of the Balkans
One of the themes we have addressed
is precisely that of the Balkans linked to the
stability of the Mediterranean area
extended here the collaboration between the
United Kingdom and Italy and very  strong
will always have to be much more coordinated
and stronger
bilateral bilateral relations which, however,
must be part of a
strong presence within NATO
I repeat to guarantee stability and peace
in the area in the Mediterranean and the Middle
East in Africa with a
different presence in  Africa more coordinated and with
a stronger presence always for
peace also in the Balkans we have a
common vision of the situation of
talks really took place in a
climate of great
positivity we have a possibility of
intentions we have identified a series of
common actions obviously we are
Great Britain  Italy strongly
committed to guaranteeing the independence
of Ukraine we are making great
efforts to support the
civilian population we are making great efforts to
also support the Ukrainian Armed Forces
in defending territorial integrity
Obviously we all want peace
and we also talked about the issue
of  Zaporigia nuclear power plant
where, for example, a
free zone area could be created to prevent
another tragedy from happening If it doesn't make
Chernobyl worse So I would really say that
the desire to collaborate in
all sectors is very very strong And we
will continue to work  together having
common goals for the coming years
We also discussed the situation in
the Indo Pacific we talked about the
relations we must have with India
that we both consider a country of
great importance a great
interlocutor naturally committed to
the fight for peace against
terrorism for  the stability of the I can
say at the end of these talks that
I am very very
satisfied with the relations which
were already good but I believe that this day
's work which will end with the
presence of our friends of also the
young British students studying
in Rome with the  Carosello dell'Arma dei
Carabinieri we know which also the
military tradition but also the
Equestrian tradition of the United Kingdom and
both our ministers have a
military past we thought we would
give them a half hour of rest
to attend our extraordinary
show that the  Arma dei Carabinieri
offers our guests
friendship family of Italy towards the
United Kingdom
Secret Rings
and exploring Outlast friend Sweet
Dreams
Paris Google
minister who Rosetto please Thank you
uncle thank the minister tajanic
free and Wallace for the opportunity to
meet we had  that
a meeting was held today involving
foreign defense according to a format that we
want to implement by cooperating more and
more with my colleague Antonio,
seeking a collaboration with the UK that
goes beyond what we have already had
for some time In the European context of the
Atlantic Alliance  a Cooperation that is becoming
increasingly important in the strategic Geo scenario
which, like today, are asking for
unity of purpose and cohesion between countries that
have always been allies
I want to thank my colleagues for
the quality of today's dialogue I
especially want to thank my
Defense colleague Ben for the cooperation  that
we already started two months ago with
our first meeting which continued at
the NATO meetings and continued
the meeting in Germany and continued
which sees us cooperate both in defense
and as the Armed Forces and also in the
industrial field for example as you know
with a  program of absolute
strategic importance such as the Global Compact
program there is the sixth generation aircraft
which has seen the United Kingdom, Italy and
Japan United in a Cooperation
which is starting and which will bear
fruit both from a
technological and  from a geostrategic and political point of view,
an initiative that had
long-term repercussions and will allow us
to prevent threats to security
in the coming decades as well. we didn't
just talk about today, we talked about
how the
foreign ministers of  defense and security at 360 degrees
starting from the eastern front but with
attention to the future Then to the
southern front to the Balkans to the Indo-
Pacific area That is, by now the times we live in
require an analytical capacity that
does not only look at what
following months But who knows how to look
at the coming decades and therefore in a
Cooperation that has always existed from a
political point of view between Italy and
Great Britain we want to continue in
this gaze that deals with I repeat
fraud in South Africa of what can
happen in that continent of the
enlarged Mediterranean but of the Endo
Pacific because by now we cannot
think that our safety and that
of our children can be defended only in
Italy only in Europe we live in a
world in which every element that can
happen thousands of kilometers away
distance then somehow touch
our economies our families
our security in such a big world
our countries are small if they don't know how
to cooperate more and more together
as we are doing with 30 other countries
for example in the alliance for Ukraine
as we have been doing for decades for
NATO as we have learned to
do in Europe but so far these
cooperations have been very political
and we must transform from
political cooperation into
human technological cooperation of economic relations
and a step forward that we must take
to have a  ever safer world to
offer to our children
likes
of Power
Real of good in the world
frostman Angela
Generations
Bagheria
Nature
brotherland friendship and that
relationship
exhortationsday
Plus Snake Classic we
have very little time let's start with the
first question Rai News Emma farnet
Germany France has  a
particular role in the ukraine Macron
This morning he reiterated a question for
minister tajani Italy does not feel
excluded or isolated in this Franco-
German axis and then with respect to ukraine a
question for both
foreign ministers at your meeting you
discussed  of new sanctions on Russia
over what is happening in Ukraine we did
not discuss a sanction
we discussed the joint commitment to
ensure Ukraine's independence
to ensure compliance with
international law to enable the
Ukrainian armed forces to defend
territorial integrity  of their country
Italy does not feel isolated at all
that the Prime Minister
spoke this morning and will meet
zielinski we feel we are protagonists
not only in the fight to defend
the independence of Ukraine It is obvious
that we are not at war with the
Russian people we are  only by defending
international law but we feel
protagonists in the Balkans we feel
protagonists in Africa I believe that the
new foreign policy of the
Italian Government which is in continuity with the
past but which wants to reinforce
our presence will show that Italy
is a protagonist country  great country
bringer of peace and stability not
only in the Mediterranean area
[Music] [
Music]
second question reiters Angel lover
[Music] [
Music]
we have the last question
ANSA Lorenzo to tanise
Greetings Minister Crosetto today
the Russian ambassador  in Italy you went back
to attacking you said that you demonize
Russia beyond one of your
comments on this I also wanted to ask you
how Italy's support will continue
also jointly with
Great Britain
for Ukraine what will be the terror
steps for  for example, the aid decree
from Italy is said
to be his intervention, for example in
Parliament, before then the actual
signing of the decree and if there has been talk
and if there has also been talk of peace That is, if
you are hypothesizing in some way
arrive at a peace table even for
the moment without the involvement of
Putin or Zenzki for example
Thanks,
the aid decree was published in the
Gazette over a week ago therefore it
was reports on the aid decree there
was a report to the copasir on
decree has been sent to the copasi But it is
now a matter of course that is, it does not
need further steps I am
sorry that we did not notice that it was
published in the Gazette signed by
me by Minister Tajani to Minister
Giorgetti 10 days ago more or less yes with
two related additions to the copasir
But look at the decree, the premise of the
decree was a
parliamentary passage in which I reported
extensively to the Senate Chamber in which
the discussion of
aid was addressed, therefore the political discussion
on the formulation and the political choice was
made with  a
parliamentary vote Among other things, the
decree widens the majority then a
technical implementation of a political decision
a technical implementation that goes on
which we need to report the course that was
done both by me who was
Minister Tajani and here from this point of
view  I don't think in a
parliamentary passage then as you know the Government
is available when the parliament
requests it for any information in
any parliamentary passage I
told us regarding the future
We are
like all other countries
cooperating with Ukraine to help it
defend itself  from this attack that seems to be experiencing
a new upsurge today and in the next few days not that we have
anything formal currently under construction We are
verifying if we have the possibility of
sending aid that is being asked of us
above all for civilian populations and
for some specific types of defense
but we will see it in the coming weeks
in the coming months as regards the
first part of the question I deal with the
defense of the country I don't have time to
devote myself to
diplomatic relations on Rome Thank you
very much this concludes the
press conference good job
How do you